ONES EVEN BEGIN UNTIL NOVEMBER
23RD.
HERE WITH REACTION.
I ACTUALLY CALLED THE INCUMBENC
PROTECTION RANKING SYSTEM OF
VOTING, AM I WRONG ON THAT?
>> YOU ARE CORRECT.
THIS WAS PUT IN PLACE BY HER
LIES IN HER CAMPAIGN STAFF THAT
WAS THIS EXPOSED IT UNDERCOVER
VIDEO SPREAD WE KNOW THE SYSTEM
WAS RIGGED IN HER FAVOR.
IT'S A GREAT HONOR AND I'M
HUMBLED AT THIS POINT THAT
ALASKANS HAVE VOTED FOR ME TO
HAVE THE LEAD IN THIS RACE OVER
A 21 YOUR INCOME BEND.
IT AS CLEAR THAT ALASKANS HAVE
GOTTEN THAT MESHES THROUGH.
WE HAVE HAD DOUBLE DEFINITE
UPHILL BATTLE AND I'M THRILLED
TO HAVE THEIR SUPPORT IT WOULD
BE GREAT.
>> TO DC AND TO SUPPORT THEM IN
THAT WAY.
>> THERE WAS ANOTHER REPUBLICAN
ON THE BALLOT THAT BOWED OUT AN
ENDORSED YOU.
THINK THAT CANDIDATE GOT CLOSE
TO 3 PERCENT OF THE VOTE,
SOMEWHERE AROUND THERE?
>> HE HAS ABOUT 3 PERCENT OF TH
VOTE AND WE'RE NOT EVEN THROUGH
ROUND ONE, SO WE DON'T HAVE THE
FINAL TARA TALLY OF WHERE WE SIT
, THIS WILL BE A LENGTHY
PROCESS AND WE NEED TO MAKE SUR
THERE AREN'T ANY GAMES PLAYED
PLAY.
WE NEED RESOURCES FOR MALLET
OBSERVERS.
HOPEFULLY WILL WE GET TO LEVEL
TWO, WHEN HIS BALLOTS DROP OFF,
WE ARE HOPING TO PICK AS MANY O
THE SECOND-PLACE VOTES AS
POSSIBLE.
WE HAVE A STRONG PATHWAY TO
VICTORY STILL.
SO YOU HAVE THEN THE NEXT
CANDIDATE, THE ONE THAT WILL BE
ELIMINATED AS A DEMOCRAT THEY
GOTTEN PERCENT OF THE VOTE.
CORRECTLY IF I'M WRONG, I THINK
IT'S WITH JOE BIDEN 56 PERCENT
OF THE TIME?
>> THAT IS CORRECT VERY CHEAP
MOSTLY VOTES DEMOCRAT SHE
SUPPORTED ALL OF HIS JUDGES AND
HIS RADICAL ENVIRONMENTALIST
NOMINEES, THESE DEMOCRATS THAT
VOTED THE DEMOCRAT FIRST, THESE
MIGHT BE PRINCIPAL DEMOCRATS WH
AREN'T GOING TO VOTE FOR A
REPUBLICAN BECAUSE WE SAW IN TH
PRIMARY AND IN THE GENERAL.
>> SO SHE VOTES WITH THE
DEMOCRATS, SO IN ALL LIKELIHOOD
A HIGH PERCENTAGE OF HER 10
PERCENT OF THE VOTES, THE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE GETTING OUT
, I DOUBT THEY ARE GOING TO
VOTE FOR YOU BECAUSE YOU ARE A
REAL CONSERVATIVE AND THEY WILL
END UP VOTING FOR LISA MURKOWSKI
.
THAT TO ME IS UNFAIR TO THE
PEOPLE OF ALASKA THEY GAVE YOU
THE MOST VOTES ON ELECTION DAY.
>> THAT IS HOW THE SYSTEM IS.
AT THE DEMOCRATS ALSO MIGHT NOT
VOTE FOR ANYBODY SECOND-PLACE.
THAT'S ALSO AN OPTION.
THEY COULD BE PARTYLINE
DEMOCRATS THEY DON'T WANT A
REPUBLICAN ADELE.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT CAME
UP FROM THE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDAT
WHEN SHE SUPPORTS LIMITS ON
ABORTIONS AND SHE SUPPORTED ALL
OF THE JUSTICES THAT OVERTURNED
ROE VERSUS WADE.
SO WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IS SITTIN
BEHIND CANDIDATE THREE AND FOUR.
WE STILL HAVE VICKI STRONG
PATHWAY TO VICTORY.
I LOVE THE STATE OF ALASKA.
BUT THIS SYSTEM YOU ALL HAVE IN
ALASKA IS PROBABLY THE DUMBEST
SYSTEM I HAVE EVER SEEN ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
I SUGGEST STRONGLY THAT YOU
CHANGE IT BECAUSE OTHERWISE,